howdy folks my name is Vic Iglesias I'm
a cloud solutions architect with Google
cloud and today I'd like to walk through
a architecture of a Kitab space CIC D
pipeline when we talk about CIC
pipelines we really have to think about
three different personas the developers
the operators and the security engineers
our developers are going to have their
own git repository where there's they
store their application code that
application code is also going to be
able to kick off continuous integration
whenever you get a commitment and that
continuous integration job is used to
create an artifact when we're talking
about deploying to kubernetes our
artifacts are container images so once
continuous integration creates that
container image it's going to store it
in a container registry that process is
going to go ahead and notify another
repository that something has changed in
that repository we have our operators
creating configuration that then says
how our application is actually going to
be deployed in order to manage that
configuration our kubernetes manifest
we're gonna use a tool called customize
customize is gonna add in that container
image reference into our config and then
commit that kubernetes set up kubernetes
manifests into a git repository that git
repository stores the state that we want
to apply into our environments the first
place where we saw that state is within
the staging branch of this repository
and that goes ahead and deploys it
straight to our staging environment now
developers can test out those changes
see them live in a staging environment
and once they're happy they're gonna
tell the operators that they want to
make a push to production or the
operators can decide to do that on their
own in order to do that they're gonna
merge from a staging branch of this
repository into the master branch and
that's gonna propagate those changes
down into the production environment now
we haven't yet talked about how we get
those production environments to be
secure the way we're going to do that is
by letting the security engineers have
their own repository that repository is
going to store the state that we're
going to use to apply policy across all
of our clusters we're going to use
anthos config management to do that
we can store that state in a repository
that has a structure that allows us to
apply to select clusters or all clusters
a certain set of configurations for
those security engineers those
configurations are going to be things
like
role-based access control policies
quotas for various applications and
things like restricting the ability of
containers to run as route so now they
can make all of those commits in an
audible get repo and then have them
apply to all of their production
infrastructure thank you for listening
please come visit us at the Google cloud
booth at cube con
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you